ça va prendre peut-être un peu plus de
temps mais il y a pas que les bactéries
aussi qui viennent décomposer valoriser
ses restes alimentaires un geste pour la
planète accompagné durant 1 heure par
Noémi conseillère prévention déchets une
vingtaine d'habitants ont appris les
bonnes pratiques avant de récupérer leur
composteur individuel depuis 2019
l'agglomération de SaintQuentin en
yeline les remet dans le cadre du Plan
compostage il vise à proposer une
solution de tri à la source pour les
biodéchets à chaque foyer une obligation
pour les collectivités territoriales
depuis le 1er janvier 2024
on a toujours tendance à dire
aujourd'hui que finalement le déchet
qu'on ne produit pas c'est le meilleur
déchet bah le plan compostage c'est un
des meilleurs exemples c'està-dire qu'on
va détourner ce flux de biodéchet pu tré
cible et compostable avant même que ça
devienne un déchet puisqu'on va
l'orienter vers le le bac à compost
c'est important pour l'environnement
d'abord parce que il y a moins à
collecter ensuite ça veut dire que on va
moins incinérer puisque nous aujourd'hui
nos déchets sont incinérés au centre de
traitement d'u du sidomp des questions
qui intéressent les habitants depuis ce
début d'année l'agglomération est passée
de une à deux distributions par semaine
et plus chur de légumes coquis d'œuf ou
marre de café chaque Français génère 83
kg de biodéchets par an un enjeu
important car cela représente environ
un/ers de nos déchets non triés
généralement les appréhensions qu'on va
avoir c'est tout d'abord les rongeurs le
fait d'attirer les rongeurs mais comme
on dit généralement les rongeurs sont
déjà là avant que le composteur arrive
et sinon ce qui revient très
généralement ce sont tout ce qui est
autour des agrumes et des oignons ce
mythe qui dit enfin qui quelque chose
c'est quelque chose qui perdure sur le
fait qu'on ne peut pas composer cette
matière organique alors que si il y a il
y a aucun souci ça m'a confirmé pas mal
d'informations que j'avais déjà et ça me
permet surtout de me dire on est on a
derrière nous une équipe qui qui a
l'habitude de recevoir toutes les
questions possibles auxquelles nous on
sera confronté et donc oui j'ai
confiance intéressant de voir qu'il y a
du monde aussi qui s'intéresse à ce
sujet et tous ensemble on va
certainement réussir à réduire la
collèue les déchets compter 25 € pour un
composteur 300 L et 30 € pour un 570 l
pour en profiter il faut habiter en
pavillon et posséder une carte déchet
depuis 2019 plus de 4000 composteurs
individuels ont été distribués à 5qutin
en yeline l'objectif serait d'équiper
12000 logements soit 20 % défoyés à
l'horizon 2030 pour le collectif
l'agglomération compte une trentaine de
points de compostage
partager